en otros vídeos hemos hablado sobre la
idea de que puede haber diferentes
versiones de un elemento dado y llamamos
a esas diferentes versiones isótopos y
cada isótopo de un elemento puede tener
una masa atómica distinta eso se deriva
de la idea de que un elemento dado
tendrá la misma cantidad de protones
pero podría tener una cantidad diferente
de neutrones ahora una pregunta que
podríamos hacernos es como los químicos
han podido averiguar cuáles son los
diversos isótopos de un elemento y su
abundancia relativa qué porcentaje de un
elemento que encontramos en el universo
es del isótopo a frente por ejemplo al
isótopo b y la respuesta a esta pregunta
es que usan una técnica conocida como
espectrometría de masas a veces se le
llama espectroscopia de masas y se
refieren esencialmente a la misma idea
en esta técnica si colocamos una pequeña
muestra aquí digamos que estamos
hablando de circonio en este ejemplo y
lo calentamos tendremos un montón de
circonio flotando y luego lo
bombardeamos con un montón de electrones
y lo que hace el bombardeo de electrones
es que puede eliminar electrones de los
átomos de la muestra ionizado hacia los
átomos y a lyon izar algunos de sus
átomos ahora tendrá un carga y debido a
que tienen carga pueden acelerarse a
través de estas placas eléctricas por lo
que ahora tenemos iones de circonio en
este caso que se mueven bastante rápido
a través de esta cámara y luego entrar
en un campo magnético y un campo
magnético fuerte puede curvar la
trayectoria puede desviar los iones con
carga para una carga dada la fuerza de
la desviación será la misma pero si
tenemos una masa más grande la
desviación será menor y si tenemos una
masa más pequeña la desviación será
mayor entonces lo que vemos aquí son los
diferentes isótopos que se desvían unos
más que otros
conforme atraviesan el campo magnético y
luego está el detector en el que se
registrara cada uno de estos isótopos en
diferentes puntos y cuantos más iones
golpeen cierta parte del detector
significará que hay más de ese tipo de
isótopos en la naturaleza y luego a
partir
eso podemos generar un gráfico que se
vea así donde el eje horizontal que a
veces lo verán etiquetado como masa
atómica y aquí están unidades de masa
atómica unificadas podemos ver que
cuando se coloca el circonio en el
espectrómetro de masas de esta manera
encontramos una pequeña parte que tiene
un número de masa de 96
hay un poco más que tiene un número de
masa de 94 92 91 y la mayor parte del
circonio más del 50% tiene un número de
masa de 90 ahora en otros casos no lo
veremos sólo en términos de masa atómica
dado en unidades de masa atómica
unificadas a veces en este eje
horizontal nos dan en términos de la
relación masa carga donde masa es la
masa pero la carga es esencialmente la
carga de los iones en el caso de que
tengamos solo una carga positiva por
ejemplo si eliminamos un electrón de los
átomos y tenemos una carga más 1
entonces la relación masa carga sería la
misma que la masa atómica medida en
unidades de masa atómica unificadas si
nuestros iones
en una carga diferente bueno entonces
tendríamos que hacer el ajuste apropiado
pero en una clase de química
introductoria la mayoría de las veces
tendremos los datos en términos de masa
atómica directamente si resulta que
tenemos algo en términos de la relación
masa carga sólo asegurémonos de hacer el
ajuste apropiado para las masas si la
carga es digamos más 2 pero esto de aquí
nos mostrará a los diversos isótopos y
su respectiva abundancia y todo proviene
de este proceso de ion izar esos átomos
acelerarlos desviarlos a través de un
campo magnético y los iones que tienen
una relación masa carga más alta se
desviarán menos ilusiones que tienen una
relación más se carga más baja se
desviarán más y podemos usar esa
información para hacer un gráfico como
éste